oh yes do it
do it do it
[Applause]
look at the [ __ ]
[Applause]
the bench loves it taco come on at least
smok taco fall
off the glass i'm telling you the bank
is open now the bank is definitely open
look at the pitch look at the bench
[Applause]
sabonis switches on to fox that's a
mismatch
fox going to try and go to work
[Applause]
he caught a couple of bodies and slammed
it home
[Applause]
fourth five big time putting the
exclamation point on that thing mark
jones
i think that hamstring is all right the
way he exploded
and just detonated
the bench went combustible when fox
exploded on
some memorable duels in the finals last
year crowder for the heat and they are
leaning on each other right now
this has become personal between these
two
cleared out lebron wants crowder shot
clock to seven
spins off of him lebron hangs the
reverse is good and look at the laker
bench
all the help and lebron again look at it
look at drumming
but they all look look
rozier cody zeller offensive rebound
[Applause]
bridges oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
a thunderbolt from bridges look at miles
bridges attack the shot blocker and
little melo
oh my word just walk all over
oh man
my goodness brandon goodwin
coming in late along with skylar bay oh
nice ball
oh my goodness there we go what's my
name man
that was fabulous he's looking over at
the benson smile he looked away
you know yes look at that twist and turn
that's going up against a seven foot two
guy dude
oh my goodness
man look at it look how look at it
[Laughter]
hardaway junior oh another steal by
kawhi
his fourth back the other way
[Music]
[Applause]
and my goodness was it a good hands play
first to steal
biker wide little three on one fast
break and
maxie klebar your elevator doesn't go
high enough
on that one kawhi
loving it just telling them look there
we go
they can tie it up or win it on a three
guy
good ball fake puppet for the
[Music]
the final is in kings win it
oh kyle guy
doing it big i said it was about cow guy
time and he rings the bell
in it and this is the moment that
he'd been training for all summer down
in los angeles
building up his body improving his skill
and he showed the preparation
the poise the perfection and the
punctuation mark
on the that's the show
intel mark jones 11 second difference
shot clock to game clock
dotson loses it walking the tightrope
oh blake griffin razzle dazzle oh
next level kevin durant
the rack attack and one of the
highlights of the year
[Applause]
of the year in the regular season finale
razzle dazzle flavor and bring in the
spice
oh this is just too good
astonishing the bop
the power
uh oh get ready play-offs are coming
now he's guarded by the lengthy durant
five to shoot colin will he's got
another
mercy light him up colin light him up in
the
lines look good shooting the ball just
haven't gotten enough shots
spurs again get it back here as patty
mills gives
lottie walker
what a dunk
his second shot is no good rebounded by
anthony
two seconds left anthony for the win
cole anthony gives the magic of victory
improbable unbelievable
in minneapolis the rookie comes through
again
in the clutch two big strong
personalities on this team
there's only one basketball these guys
understand
how to play with one another and how to
win as another three
here by the brooklyn nets
lakers just keep coming at you
morris in the corner lebron has time to
set read the label put it up for three
look at that bench for the l.a
look at lebron in the corner in front of
his bench and watch the bench behind him
they exploded in excitement
again do it again oh do it again yes oh
you gotta put it on the floor
[Applause]
124 to 95.
if you stuck with us to the very end
here